c'est une mise en scène comme tout
discours c'est un corps c'est une voie
et c'est un message parler c'est aussi
faire surgir des images corporellement
vocalement il se laisse aller à quelque
chose de plus libres ce qui manifeste
que il a plus confiance en lui
officiers sous-officiers officiers
mariniers soldats marins nos
compatriotes connaissent votre
efficacité
vous soutiennent
mon font confiance et ils ont raison le
discours de voeux du président de la
république aux forces armées à la fois
un moment rituel à un moment obligé est
un moment important on sait que le
rapport d' emmanuel macron aux forces
armées a démarré sur un mauvais pied
puisque dès le début de son quinquennat
il avait eu cette phrase un peu brutale
je suis votre chef ce discours pour moi
ces quatre shows c'est une mise en scène
comme tout discours c'est un corps c'est
une voie et c'est un message sur la mise
en scène il faut bien dire que la
scénographie du discours est très étudié
on est dans un chapiteau un chapiteau un
peu sombre où seul et éclairé le pupitre
du président de la république le reste
du public et dans la pénombre pénombre
qui permet d'apercevoir la silhouette de
blindés donc il y à l'idée aussi une
démonstration de force donc déjà dans la
scénographie s'est dit quelque chose du
rapport entre emmanuel macron et les
forces armées il entre de façon très
solennelle avec les deux ministres a à
ses côtés les plus hauts gradés dernière
lubie et donc tout cela au manifeste une
volonté d' en imposer ensuite et il y a
la question du corps et avoir encore
assez expressif quand il dit on va aller
de l'avant on va continuer on va aller
plus loin on va déployer il va faire des
gestes comme ça pour aller vers l'avant
qui illustre son propos dans une sorte
de de congruence entre le discours et le
corps et quand il dit eh bien on va
réarmer on va renforcer à voir des
gestes comme ça de deux poings fermés
quand il va dire on fait en européen il
va y avoir des gestes de rassemblement
donc il va essayer et d'incarner et le
plus possible de son discours d'un point
de vue corporelle même si encore une
fois il est derrière un pupitre et que
le langage corporel est très contraint
mais la marge de liberté dont ils
disposent ils utilisent après au delà
donc de la mise en scène du corps il y a
la question de la voix et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que là encore les
techniques vocales vont être mises au
service d'une lutte contre le trop grand
formalisme d'un discours passages
obligés comme le discours de voeux à
coup sûr une aile pm à hauteur d'homme
mais une indispensable lp/m pour
continuer à innover et anticiper car
nous vivons une période de retour du
tragique mais d' accélération de
l'histoire brutalement il va y avoir un
débit qui va s'accélérer et on voit très
bien dans le discours à quel moment
emmanuel macron suit scrupuleusement son
texte mais là il va avoir ce qu'on
appelle une prosodie c'est à dire les
variations la musicalité de la voix il
va avoir une prosodie un peu obligé est
un peu monochrome
de toutes ces missions
la france a continué d'être mobilisés
sur les théâtres d'opérations et puis
les moments où il sort de son texte ou
de toute évidence il est en situation
d'improvisation et très rapidement son
discours va être beaucoup plus naturelle
beaucoup plus fluide et beaucoup moins
saccadée les nouvelles formes hybrides
de confidentialité de nouveaux théâtres
d'opération ce qui paraissait impensable
de nouvelles technologies
les faits
nous ont donné raison bien plus tôt que
nous le pensions et donc il y a dans la
voix également la question des accents
pour lutter contre la monotonie par
exemple à un moment il parle d'une loi
de programmation militaire de réparation
et il ne dit pas une loi de
programmation militaire de réparation il
dit une olp m de réparation on voit bien
qu'il ait souhaité mettre un accent il a
souhaité que cette idée d'une réparation
soit mise en lumière comme un spot qui
l'isolent en quelque sorte et qui le
renforce dans le discours d'une façon
générale et donc vous avez de temps en
temps des mots qui ressorte parce que
vocalement on leur donne un coup de
projecteur qui les isole du reste du
discours l'innovation n'est pas
seulement dans les équipements mais la
manière aussi de concevoir les
évolutions les nouvelles techniques les
scénarios du futur qui parfois arrive je
dois bien l'avouer plus vite qu'on ne le
pensait et là il ya un côté eux note
pour soi même à côté aparté personnel un
peu énigmatique on a l'impression que ce
je dois bien l'avouer est une sorte de
connivence peut être avec lui mais
peut-être avec ce qu'ils l'écoutent mais
qu'il ne va pas explicité qu'il y ait
une sorte de mystère et que si je dois
bien l'avouer est peut-être une sorte de
réflexion même hors discours ou
emmanuel macron parle peut-être de la
campagne présidentielle peut-être de la
crise du profil et après sur sur le fond
bah emmanuel mâcon va mobiliser toutes
les recettes d'un discours on va avoir
évidemment des figures de style beaucoup
de figures de style il va y avoir d anna
fort c'est quand il se passe aussi quand
il se passe cela quand il advient ceci
donc ils renforcent keith combes et qui
rythme le discours qui va les voir c'est
anna fort il va y avoir beaucoup de
métaphores également c'est à dire des
images les grandes tendances les lignes
de forces et mouvements de fond de
l'histoire sont certes enveloppé d'un
brouillard qui nous n'y prêtons garde
pourrait nous conduire à négliger le
temps long et lointain ans qu'il serait
un prédictive imprévisible
et ce serait une folie
que de perdre de vue
l'horizon en se focalisant sur la
prochaine l'âme le prochain nuage non il
nous faut chercher à connaître à
anticiper il a très petit le jeu mais
vous avez aussi lutter nous avons décidé
nous avons défini nous avons continué à
nous déployer
précisément il va à la fort de son
discours quasiment pour la première fois
dire jeu avec des mots qui ne sont plus
des mots techniques qui sont des mots de
sentiments demain comme aujourd'hui
fait mon ambition est l'objectif que je
vous assigne en cohérence
et en confiance on aurait pu avoir une
fin extrêmement ronflante extrêmement
enthousiaste et en réalité il va choisir
de se terminer par quelque chose de très
personnel je vais ici vous dire ce soir
que
la nation française et fière de vous
et qu'à titre personnel
je suis au combien fier
depuis bientôt cinq ans
d'être là où je suis
à vos côtés je crois qu'on peut dire que
ce discours manifeste une forme des gens
se retrouvent et du président de la
république face aux forces armées parce
que précisément dans d'anciens discours
il était très crispé et réfugiés
corporellement vocalement il se laisse
aller à quelque chose de plus libre de
plus naturel de plus spontané ce qui
manifeste qu'il a plus confiance en lui
dans ce rapport avec les forces armées
et qu'il n'est pas dans la crainte
permanente de commettre un impair